près de carquif en terrain reconquille
ces derniers mois par les forces
ukrainiennes près de cette tranchée des
volontaires cherchent des corps fauchés
par la guerre qu'importe leur camp
Agne
scientifique il poursuivent leur
recherche d'indices
a été identifié nous allons tenter de
les changer sa famille sera informé du
lieu de son décès
de quoi raviver l'espoir de récupérer
les dépouilles de leur compatriotes
ukrainien
il est important pour nous d'échanger
les corps des soldats russes contre ceux
des nôtres
donc nous recueillons ces dépouilles
pour les échanger
sans cela les Russes ne nous
laisseraient pas à récupérer nos morts
un travail de fourmi qui devrait prendre
des années vendredi dernier Vladimir
Poutine recevait à Moscou des mers et
épouse d'hommes mobilisés en Ukraine son
objectif calmer la colère croissante
d'un groupe dans l'opinion pèse en
Russie depuis des semaines le pouvoir
russe s'est mis sous pression par les
critiques répétées de proches de
mobiliser quand elles en reçoivent
certaines familles doivent se contenter
d'informations parcellaires sur les
circonstances de la mort de leurs
proches les condamnant à un deuil quasi
impossible